Bienvenido de nuevo a Computación Cuántica en Práctica. Este es el episodio 6. Hoy nos vamos a centrar en una de mis
aplicaciones favoritas de las computadoras cuánticas: simular la naturaleza. En este episodio, vamos a hablar de los pasos necesarios
para hacerlo con cualquier tipo de problema de dinámica cuántica, que es el problema de encontrar cómo la descripción de un
sistema cuántico cambia con el tiempo. Lo haremos primero a alto nivel y luego veremos un ejemplo específico y lo analizaremos
en detalle. En concreto, el experimento de IBM de 2023 que demostró la utilidad cuántica. Para una motivación rápida al
inicio, una de las historias más famosas que quienes trabajamos en el campo de la computación cuántica contamos una y otra vez,
la historia de Richard Feynman dando una conferencia en Caltech en 1959 y básicamente
ofreciendo motivación para todo el campo durante décadas. El discurso se llamó "Hay mucho espacio en el
fondo". Un título curioso, pero la idea básica era que afirmaba que todavía había mucha física rica por
descubrir a nivel microscópico.
A esa charla en concreto no se le prestó mucha atención hasta los años 80, cuando la tecnología había avanzado bastante. Y Feynman
también fue aclarando y refinando su mensaje con el tiempo. Volvió a Caltech en los 80 y presentó otro artículo llamado
"Simulando la naturaleza con computadoras", donde dijo específicamente que quería hablar sobre la posibilidad de que exista una
simulación exacta en la que la computadora haga exactamente lo mismo que la naturaleza.
pudiendo así deshacerse de las aproximaciones burdas de lo que ocurre a escala atómica y reemplazarlas con
computadoras que entiendan y aprovechen la física cuántica para no solo simular lo que hace la naturaleza, sino emularla.
Recuerda este gráfico de línea de tiempo que mostré en un episodio anterior. En un extremo, teníamos problemas que eran fáciles de
resolver y que no requerirán ningún tipo de aceleración que lo cuántico pueda ofrecer. Pero en el otro extremo, tenemos problemas que son
muy difíciles y necesitan máquinas cuánticas tolerantes a fallos que aún no tenemos.
Por suerte, creemos que hay bastantes problemas de simulación que se encuentran aquí en el medio, que es la región en la que
podemos trabajar actualmente. Y hay muchas razones para estar emocionados e intrigados por esta perspectiva, porque la
simulación de la naturaleza es la base de muchas áreas de aplicación apasionantes. Solo por nombrar algunas. Si pudiéramos
simular mejor la naturaleza, podríamos acelerar el descubrimiento de nuevos materiales, crear mejores fármacos y medicamentos, o
incluso explorar nueva física subyacente a la física de partículas o la cosmología. Pero antes de que tú, yo o cualquiera pueda intentar
aplicar la computación cuántica a estas emocionantes áreas por ahora, necesitarán entender los pasos básicos en un
flujo de trabajo típico basado en simulación.
Primero, querrás identificar un sistema cuántico de interés. Esto te informará sobre el Hamiltoniano que gobierna su evolución
temporal y una descripción significativa de sus propiedades iniciales o su estado.
Luego tendrás que encontrar un método apropiado para implementar la evolución temporal de este estado. Con estos ingredientes
resueltos, los siguientes pasos implican llevar a cabo el experimento real.
Estos generalmente implican optimizar la implementación del circuit cuántico del algoritmo de evolución temporal, ejecutar el
circuit o los circuits en hardware cuántico y post-procesar los resultados. Así que
podemos nombrar los pasos básicos involucrados en un experimento de simulación de la siguiente manera.
Identificar el Hamiltoniano del sistema, codificación del Hamiltoniano, preparación del estado, evolución del estado,
optimización del circuit, ejecución del circuit y post-procesamiento.
Pero estos son pasos bastante detallados. Recuerda que las cuatro etapas del framework de patrones de Qiskit, que nos ayuda
a entender cómo implementar una rutina en Qiskit, son: mapeo, optimización del circuit, ejecución del circuit y
post-procesamiento. Así que estos cuatro primeros pasos aquí están todos incluidos bajo el paraguas del mapeo, y por eso
dedicamos un episodio entero a esta primera etapa, y si te lo perdiste, por favor vuelve atrás y mira el episodio anterior.
Ahora primero recorramos lo que significan estos pasos antes de adentrarnos en cualquier código. Así que lo primero básico que necesitamos
hacer para realizar un experimento de simulación es identificar el Hamiltoniano que describe el sistema. A veces, y
a menudo, estos son bien conocidos; otras veces tenemos que construirlo a partir de la comprensión de las contribuciones energéticas
de los pequeños subconjuntos del sistema completo, como aquí, donde hi es el Hamiltoniano que actúa sobre uno de los n subsistemas de h.
También necesitaremos saber si el sistema consiste en fermiones o bosones, si estamos tratando con partículas elementales. A continuación,
necesitamos codificar el Hamiltoniano y traducirlo a términos que las computadoras cuánticas puedan entender. Muchas veces,
estos Hamiltonianos estarán compuestos de partículas elementales o sistemas de espín. Si estuviéramos simulando fermiones o bosones,
necesitaríamos elegir una transformación de codificación como la Jordan-Wigner o la Bravyi-Kitaev. Estas transformaciones
nos dirán cómo traducir la definición del Hamiltoniano escrito en términos de los componentes originales —los fermiones o
bosones— en operadores de Pauli que se convierten fácilmente en gates en una computadora cuántica. Por ejemplo, la transformación Jordan-Wigner
definida aquí proporciona un mapeo de operadores fermiónicos a operadores de Pauli. Si ya estamos trabajando
con sistemas de espín 1/2, que son muy comunes, entonces estamos listos, salvo posibles coeficientes de normalización,
y no necesitamos usar un esquema de codificación. Habiendo codificado el Hamiltoniano deseado en el conjunto de gates de la computadora cuántica,
el siguiente paso crucial es determinar el estado cuántico inicial apropiado desde el cual comenzar nuestra
simulación. Este estado debería reflejar idealmente algún significado físico o configuración del
sistema bajo estudio. Por ejemplo, si nos interesa explorar la energía del estado base de una molécula, podríamos
empezar con una aproximación de Hartree-Fock u otra fácilmente preparable que tenga una superposición significativa con el verdadero
estado base. La elección del estado base inicial afecta no solo la convergencia de los algoritmos variacionales
como VQE, el solucionador cuántico variacional, sino también la precisión y eficiencia de
la evolución temporal o el muestreo en la estimación de fase cuántica. En esencia, el estado inicial sirve como el
punto de lanzamiento para el cálculo, estableciendo el escenario para extraer observables útiles sobre el sistema cuántico
que estamos modelando. La preparación de un estado arbitrario de n qubits, donde ci son los estados de la base computacional y ai es
el coeficiente respectivo de cada estado y la condición de normalización 2 a la n menos uno, generalmente puede abordarse
inicializando el estado con el operador o; el estado de partida sería el estado de base estándar todo ceros, escrito a menudo
así por simplicidad. En general, esto requiere un número exponencial de gates CNOT. A menudo nos
interesa un estado inicial específico para el sistema y su preparación puede implementarse con una cantidad razonable
de recursos. Los estados producto, por ejemplo, en los que los qubits no están entrelazados entre sí, solo requieren operaciones de un solo
qubit. Aún no hemos tenido la oportunidad de hablar sobre la trotterización,
aunque algunos de ustedes probablemente ya estén familiarizados con ella. En esencia, la trotterización es un método para calcular la exponenciación de matrices que
usa aproximaciones para manejar la naturaleza exponencial de los operadores no conmutativos. Cuando dos operadores como HA
y HB no conmutan, entonces debemos aplicar un truco ingenioso y alternativamente aplicar los exponenciales correspondientes de
e a la menos i ha y e a la menos i hb un número n de
veces. Los operadores de evolución alternantes se aplican. No voy a repasar la demostración aquí, pero compartiré un enlace
a una prueba sencilla de esta afirmación en la descripción. Pero el mensaje clave es este. La evolución temporal es una
parte importante del mapeo también. La trotterización divide una interacción continua en pasos discretos que pueden
implementarse en una computadora cuántica. Después de generar el circuit trotterizado, finalmente hemos terminado el
paso de mapeo. Ahora podemos pasar a la optimización del circuit.
Para hacer eso, esto es lo que hay que lograr. Se necesita un diseño de qubit que mapee los qubits virtuales del
circuit a los físicos del hardware. Esto es necesario porque el hardware puede tener topologías particulares
que restringen la interacción directa de los qubits físicos. Mientras que la implementación de
un circuit cuántico suele asumir la capacidad de que cualquier qubit interactúe con cualquier otro qubit. Luego necesitamos insertar
gates de intercambio según sea necesario para enrutar interacciones entre qubits que no están conectados. Necesitamos traducir los
gates de nuestro circuit a instrucciones de arquitectura de conjunto de instrucciones o instrucciones ISA que
pueden ejecutarse directamente en el hardware. Luego necesitamos realizar optimizaciones del circuit para minimizar
la profundidad del circuit y el conteo de gates. Este paso también puede realizarse en el circuit virtual. El circuit donde los qubits
aún no han sido mapeados a una topología de dispositivo. Pero recuerda que gran parte de esto se hace automáticamente para ti en
Qiskit. Veremos exactamente cómo en la siguiente sección de esta clase. Después del paso de optimización, estamos listos para ejecutar
el circuit usando una primitiva. Para la mayoría de los experimentos de simulación, te interesa comprender el cambio
de ciertas propiedades del sistema con el tiempo. Por eso es probable que uses la primitiva estimador, porque eso
te permitirá medir los valores de expectativa de los observables correspondientes a propiedades específicas. Luego
configuraremos las mejores opciones para el estimador, que puede añadir técnicas de supresión y mitigación de errores. Finalmente, ejecutaremos el
experimento. El último paso es postprocesar todos los datos. Esto extrae los valores de expectativa medidos o, si
estás usando el sampler, la distribución de probabilidad muestral en la base computacional. Si todo lo que se necesita
son los valores de expectativa de los observables de interés, estos pueden obtenerse directamente del estimador
tanto en sus valores brutos como en los mitigados por errores. Muchas veces se usarán los valores de expectativa medidos
para otros cálculos de otras cantidades de interés que no requieren computación cuántica y pueden ser
calculadas en una computadora clásica.
Ahora vamos a recorrer un ejemplo real de un artículo muy influyente que IBM publicó hace un par de años llamado
"evidencia de la utilidad de la computación cuántica antes de la tolerancia a fallos". Este artículo, que abreviamos cariñosamente como
el artículo de utilidad, se convirtió en un trabajo muy influyente en el campo de la computación cuántica casi de inmediato tras su publicación.
La tesis general del artículo es que una computadora cuántica ruidosa produjo resultados precisos o valores de expectativa
usando 127 qubits y 2.880 gates, más allá de las capacidades de la computación por fuerza
bruta, que es la simulación exacta de los circuits cuánticos ejecutados por el hardware. Este trabajo también fue
importante porque demostró que una computadora cuántica podía usarse para verificar o comparar resultados con otros
métodos clásicos aproximados para simulaciones cuánticas, como los algoritmos de redes tensoriales, donde la solución
no se conocía de antemano. Lo que también es bastante interesante es que ahora otros, usando los sistemas cuánticos de IBM en
la nube y Qiskit, pueden duplicar y verificar estos resultados por su cuenta.
Voy a explicarte cómo hacerlo. Para este ejemplo, vamos a ser un poco más específicos sobre los
pasos involucrados en mapear este problema en entradas que pueda entender un dispositivo cuántico. En este caso, estaremos
simulando la dinámica de la magnetización total de un sistema de espines de dipolo magnético en una red bajo la influencia de
un campo magnético externo. El sistema puede describirse mediante un modelo de Ising con un campo magnético transversal.
Lo modelamos con un circuit cuántico parametrizado donde los parámetros corresponden al valor ajustable de la
interacción espín-espín o Z y la intensidad del campo magnético X. Ahora bien,
esta serie se llama computación cuántica en la práctica. Por eso, también vamos a analizar los procedimientos de este experimento
que implementaremos para obtener los mejores resultados posibles. A continuación, vamos a hablar de cómo eliminar
qubits defectuosos o qubits con baja fidelidad de gate o tiempos de decoherencia cortos, lo que podría afectar drásticamente los
resultados experimentales. Estos qubits defectuosos pueden aparecer debido a una calibración previa deficiente
o por sistemas de dos niveles que interactúan con el qubit. Eliminar algunos qubits de la topología nativa del hardware equivale a
considerar un sistema en una red descrita por la topología resultante. También vamos a hablar sobre la creación del
circuit cuántico parametrizado que implementa la evolución temporal del sistema mediante trotterización.
Para ello, será importante identificar las capas de entrelazamiento, que son una parte fundamental de la principal técnica de
mitigación de errores que vamos a usar más adelante. En este punto quiero asegurarme de que tú, la audiencia, sepas
que puedes seguir todo lo que voy a explicar en el tutorial enlazado abajo y en la plataforma de
aprendizaje cuántico de IBM. En este tutorial, lo que podrías notar es que hemos creado una serie de funciones auxiliares
al inicio del notebook que podemos invocar más adelante para facilitarnos un poco la vida. Quiero mencionar estas
ahora, no porque sea parte del proceso oficial o formal, sino porque esto es lo que los experimentalistas suelen hacer
en la vida real para ayudarles a ejecutar este tipo de experimentos. Y también nos muestra cómo vamos a desglosar nuestro
problema aún más. Las funciones que definimos en el notebook son las siguientes. Eliminar acoplamientos de qubits.
Definir acoplamientos de qubits. Construir los acoplamientos de capas. Construir las capas de entrelazamiento. Y por último, definir el circuit trotterizado.
A continuación, hablemos de los acoplamientos de capas, que ayudan a definir cómo interactúan los qubits
con sus vecinos durante la simulación. Nuestros dispositivos cuánticos usan algo llamado diseño hexagonal pesado,
un patrón especial para conectar qubits. En este diseño, podemos agrupar las conexiones llamadas aristas en tres
conjuntos separados donde ninguna de las dos conexiones del mismo conjunto comparte un qubit. Esto es
importante porque en una computadora cuántica real, no podemos ejecutar gates de dos qubits al mismo tiempo si involucran el
mismo qubit. Cada qubit solo puede estar involucrado en un gate a la vez. Al
dividir todas las conexiones en tres capas, podemos aplicar gates de dos qubits en todo el dispositivo en tres
rondas, asegurándonos de que ningún qubit se use en más de un gate por capa. Estos
gates implementan la interacción ZZ del modelo de Ising, y se repiten en cada paso de la simulación llamado el
paso de Trotter. El twirling modifica el ruido en el dispositivo para que incluso un modelo de ruido simple
sea probable que sea preciso. Esto también hace posible aprender con precisión el modelo de ruido y usar la información obtenida
en técnicas de mitigación de errores.
A continuación, tenemos que eliminar nuestros qubits defectuosos de nuestra lista posible de qubits físicos que podemos usar para el
experimento. Como dije, un qubit puede volverse defectuoso por una variedad de razones diferentes. A veces es solo una mala
calibración, un simple error que puede resolverse simplemente calibrando de nuevo.
A veces es un poco más complicado y está relacionado con algo que llamamos TLS, que es un sistema interfacial de dos niveles
defecto que lleva a fluctuaciones de parámetros del qubit y a la relajación. Esto se puede
resolver calentando un poco todo el sistema y luego enfriándolo de nuevo. Pero eso lleva tiempo y no es posible hacerlo
a través de la nube. Así que por ahora, lo más fácil es simplemente excluirlos de nuestra lista de posibles
qubits físicos que usaremos. Puedes identificar fácilmente qué qubits no se están comportando como se espera desde la plataforma IBM Quantum.
Puedes graficar las características del qubit en la plataforma o descargarlas como CSV. Luego crea una lista de todos los
qubits que quieres excluir y simplemente quítalos de la lista de qubits físicos totales del dispositivo.
Muy bien. Continuemos con nuestro paso de mapeo generando nuestro circuit troterizado. Como mostramos
antes, la troterización discretiza la evolución temporal en una serie de pasos y necesitamos decidir cuántos pasos usar.
Elegiremos seis aquí. Pero en general, la estrategia es equilibrar lo que se llama el error de Trotter, que es un
error de aproximación algorítmica, con el error derivado de la decoherencia. Más pasos de Trotter reducen el error de aproximación
pero requieren circuits cuánticos más profundos que experimentan más ruido de decoherencia. Vamos a definir el
circuit en términos del parámetro theta, que es la intensidad del campo magnético externo, los acoplamientos de capas y el
número de pasos y qubits y, por supuesto, el backend del dispositivo. Debido a la
dependencia de la magnetización del sistema en la intensidad del campo magnético externo, es interesante
ejecutar la simulación con distintos valores de la intensidad del campo magnético, que se traducen en diferentes ángulos de RX en
la rotación para RX en el circuit. Ahora que hemos generado nuestro circuit, pasamos a su optimización.
El primer paso es definir un gestor de pasos. Recuerda que en el contexto del SDK de Qiskit, la transpolación se refiere al
proceso de transformar un circuit de entrada en una forma adecuada para su ejecución en un dispositivo cuántico.
La transpolación ocurre normalmente en una secuencia de pasos llamados transpiler passes. Un gestor de pasos es un objeto que
almacena una lista de transpiler passes y puede ejecutarlos en un circuit. Crea un gestor de pasos inicializando un objeto
gestor de pasos con una lista de transpiler passes. Al final, nuestro gestor de pasos
creará un circuit ISA, un circuit que debe estar escrito en términos de la arquitectura del conjunto de instrucciones del backend,
que describe el circuit y los gates nativos del backend pero sin la información de temporización necesaria para ejecutar el
circuit. Ahora estamos listos para ejecutar nuestro circuit, que es el paso tres de los patrones de Qiskit. Como se mencionó antes, usaremos
definitivamente el estimador como nuestra primitiva de elección para este experimento, ya que queremos medir la
magnetización total del sistema, y estimar el valor esperado de los observables es exactamente para lo que fue diseñado el estimador.
En este paso también será crucial especificar nuestras opciones de mitigación de errores. Usaremos extrapolación de ruido cero
para obtener los mejores resultados posibles. En particular, en el tutorial verás que especificamos dos o más
valores de factor de ruido con los que evaluar los modelos extrapolados, y especificamos
amplificación probabilística de errores como nuestra opción de amplificación. Ahora bien, la amplificación
probabilística de errores, o PA, fue realmente la técnica de mitigación de errores preferida aquí porque escala mucho mejor
que las otras opciones. Y eso es lo que importa cuando trabajamos al nivel de más de 100 qubits.
Por último, ejecuta el experimento; tardará un tiempo en completarse, pero por ahora hagamos referencia a los datos
en cola y almacenados del tutorial. Examinaremos los metadatos prestando especial atención a los gates en capas y
las capas mitigadas, ya que estamos a punto de usarlos para eliminar un montón de errores de nuestros datos en bruto. Ya casi estamos listos
para graficar nuestros resultados finales. Pero antes de hacerlo, añadamos rápidamente un interludio aquí sobre qué significa exactamente la extrapolación de ruido cero,
o ZNE. Lo hemos visto brevemente en episodios anteriores, pero para repasarlo, la extrapolación de ruido cero
es una técnica de mitigación de errores que elimina los efectos de un ruido desconocido durante la ejecución del circuit y que puede ser
escalado de una manera conocida. Asume que los valores esperados escalan con el ruido mediante una función conocida que se muestra aquí, donde los
parámetros lambda especifican la intensidad del ruido y pueden amplificarse. Podemos implementar ZNE con los siguientes pasos.
Primero, amplifica el ruido del circuit para varios factores de ruido: lambda 1, lambda 2,
lambda 3, etcétera. Ejecuta cada circuit con ruido amplificado para medir el
valor esperado a de lambda 1, a de lambda 2, etcétera. Y luego extrapola de vuelta al límite de ruido cero:
el valor esperado a de cero.
El principal desafío para implementar ZNE con éxito es tener un modelo preciso del ruido en el valor esperado
y amplificar el ruido de una manera conocida.
Hay tres formas comunes en las que se implementa la amplificación de errores para ZNE: escalar la duración del pulso mediante calibración,
repetir gates en ciclos de identidad y añadir ruido mediante canales de muestreo de Pauli.
Llamamos a este último PA. La amplificación probabilística de errores es la mejor opción aquí porque el estiramiento de pulsos es muy
costoso computacionalmente. El plegado de gates carece de garantías teóricas para preservar el sesgo del ruido. Pero PA se puede
aplicar a cualquier circuit que pueda ejecutarse con factores de ruido nativos, aunque requiere aprender el modelo de ruido. PA asume
el mismo modelo de ruido basado en capas que la cancelación probabilística de errores.
Sin embargo, evita la sobrecarga de muestreo que escala exponencialmente con el ruido del circuit. Para aprender el modelo de ruido,
primero debemos identificar las capas únicas de operaciones de dos qubits en el circuit.
Para cada capa, aplica un twirl de Pauli a los gates de dos qubits para asegurarte de que el ruido esté bien descrito por un modelo de ruido de amortiguamiento.
Repite pares de capas identidad a profundidad variable y finalmente ajusta una fidelidad o un error para cada canal de ruido. Y
por supuesto, aunque te recomiendo entender este método hasta cierto punto, hacerlo a mano en Qiskit es
mucho más sencillo, como se muestra en el tutorial. Ahora, finalmente, veamos los datos graficados. La línea
gris punteada muestra los resultados exactos obtenidos con métodos clásicos aproximados, con un error de aproximación
que converge a un umbral bajo. Como puedes ver, los datos en bruto para los distintos factores de ruido que elegimos al
principio se alejan bastante de esa línea punteada. La línea azul sólida muestra los datos teniendo en cuenta nuestro procesamiento ZNE.
Y puedes ver de inmediato que está mucho más cerca de los resultados exactos.
En resumen, los valores ruidosos muestran una gran desviación respecto a los valores exactos. Los
valores mitigados están cercanos a los valores exactos, lo que demuestra la utilidad de la técnica de mitigación basada en PA.
Y eso concluye esencialmente este episodio. Para resumir rápidamente lo que hemos aprendido: la simulación cuántica es una de
las áreas de aplicación más prometedoras a corto y mediano plazo.
Tiene aplicaciones de amplio alcance, desde la industria farmacéutica hasta la física de altas energías,
las ciencias de materiales y más. El artículo de utilidad de IBM publicado en 2023 marcó
el camino hacia el uso de computadoras cuánticas para el descubrimiento científico. Y trabajamos en detalle a través del
tutorial asociado a ese artículo. Los pasos para resolver un problema de simulación de principio a fin
son relativamente sencillos, especialmente una vez que te acostumbras. Y mi esperanza es que
de ahora en adelante puedas usar este video y el tutorial como guía para aún más problemas de simulación en el futuro.
Gracias por ver y nos vemos la próxima vez en Quantum Computing in Practice.